higher education is the sponsor of this
enormous entertainment industry it's
building that industry on the backs of
an unrecognized labor force college
football season has returned and with it
the debate over paying college athletes
they're already among the brightest
sports stars bringing in millions for
their schools and TV so why not pay
student athletes last year the NCAA made
1 billion dollars in revenue but the
organization continues to resist paying
student athletes because they say it
would undermine the idea of amateurism
these are our students and they will be
students and they will play these games
around the concept of collegiate
athletics or amateurism well the term
the student-athletes actually a fiction
it was created to obscure the fact that
the NCAA knew that it had created a
paper plate system that's dr. Alan
Starsky a sport management professor at
Drexel University Straus Key has studied
the issue of paper play for years and
was once a student athlete herself when
you look at how a mannerism is
constructed within the NCAA you find
that it's really a floating definition
it's the definition of convenience the
change is over time the NCAA has three
different divisions and there aren't
different definitions of amateurism for
each one of those divisions popular
opinion seems to be shifting in favor of
pay-for-play a recent reason Route poll
shows that 64% of Americans think
college athletes should receive some
portion of revenue generated by the use
of their likeness but if we're going to
pay student athletes how do we begin to
determine their worth in a fair market
when removing whom and I started out to
do these series of studies there was no
real discussion about what the potential
market value of a college football in
best men's basketball player might be
and so we looked out at the landscape
and we said well what would give us at
least some sense of what that value
would be and it seemed reasonable that
we would go to the
professional associations where there's
a revenue sharing mechanism in place and
so we looked at the NFL and we looked at
the NBA working with the national
college Players Association stravsky
produced one of the first reports
looking up the potential worth of
college football and basketball players
we looked at what the revenue sharing
would be in the NFL for example where
players receive forty six point five
percent of the revenue generated and we
applied that formula to major college
football programs and what you see if
you look at a school like Ohio State for
example Ohio State in 2013-2014 brought
in an approximately 63 million dollars
if you apply that forty six point five
percent in terms of revenue sharing that
comes out to about three hundred fifty
nine thousand per player while their
athletic scholarship is valued at about
twenty-seven thousand their actual value
is about three hundred is over three
hundred thousand and over the course of
four years that translates into about
1.2 million per player but I think in
general if we're looking at college
football players for the years 20 2013
2014 the average value of a football
player a college football player would
be about 110,000 across all division 1
football the language schools and sure
college athletes probably shouldn't be
paid the same rate as a professional but
stravsky argues the two markets aren't
that far apart we can look at the top
five conferences the the power 5 as
they're called and not only is it just
an institutional investment in those
football programs we have enormous
corporate investment corporate entities
that build some part of their business
on those games so we have ESPN with
their empire which has built several of
their channels quite specifically on
college football
we have Nike as an industry that uses
college football to market its apparel
and its footwear all those industries
have a slice of the labor that is going
on
field and so if we begin to really look
at the expanse of money that is out
there the question isn't so much for me
whether or not the industry can afford
to pay athletes it's just a matter of
when there will be a recognition of the
vast amount of profit that is being
generated in all of these other sectors
and for people to understand that there
really is money out there to do it well
the money may be there to do it the NCAA
has been slow to make any changes this
inaction has led to a multitude of
lawsuits challenging the power structure
of the organization along with
northwestern football's historic bid to
unionize in terms of the issue of
unionization I think that it is
important that athletes be recognized in
the profit sports as employees because
within the the way in which their
reality exists on campus they are in
another region where they are really not
employees nor are they students and as a
result of that they have no portal to
actually gain access to their rights
when an athlete comes on campus they're
told that they are playing as a matter
of privilege not as a right and because
it's a privilege they can then agree to
give up all manner of rights so the
athletic department may impose all kinds
of rules related to their conduct and
then the school slowly but surely begins
to strip away their rights to due
process and other things like that now
having said all of that are there going
to be issues associated with
unionization absolutely but what that
opens the door to is it opens the door
to the possibility of collective
bargaining and that is something that
would help athletes tremendously because
they would then have a mechanism of that
see and they would also have control
over the rules that have been governing
their lives though the national
relations labor board recently refused
to take up the northwestern case the
NCAA responded to the suit by enacting
major policy reforms that will increase
a college athlete scholarship to cover
the full cost of attendance Straus Key
will have to update her figures thanks
to the new bylaw but she says this
example is exactly why an outside
advocacy group representing the interest
of student athletes is needed in the
reform effort we know that this is a
starting point in the conversation we
know that it isn't a be-all and end-all
but we also know that our estimate is
far more representative of the kind of
inequities that exist exist in the
system then simply just accepting that
the scholarship is the only measure